again this is our not first viewing just
assume all for X month this is not gonna
be first viewings this is my first
viewing in a way yeah while yeah me too
as I've seen the x-men one I saw
multiple times just because they would
run it on TV a lot mmm
I didn't see this win the back when I
had cable I didn't see this one on TV as
much I don't know if I just rug for
years it was the best one the greatest
one and like I was about to get us the
first one what do you think I don't
remember liking the story more but I
remember thinking this one like had more
energy which is something the first one
is sort of a little bit more at risk
what do we find out about Wolverines
past nothing that's the Achilles heel of
both this and spider-man both of these
films series move in a snail's pace they
yeah you really don't learn it from
trilogy they're trying to honor it yeah
what here we go this is I haven't seen
this in years so we'll see if it's it's
see if it still holds up is like the
best out of see if I liked you better
the next one yeah show you understand
x-men still early two-thousands kind of
bland but I like this credit sequence
better well it's more solid yeah
so it is an x-men United know that I
think I was an ass yeah this is like
some advertising trick yeah Lincoln was
a mutant this is my Patrick's you're
narrating this but like Arnold from
Total Recall the commentary just like
these people are looking around as a
person with a heart and wide-angle lens
that's going to be exploited quite a bit
in this movie oh it's Nixon Bush yeah
he's kind of Nixon he's Nix ish
President Nixon I remember thinking this
intro was super clear yeah and again
this intro had like all the energy that
like I kind of wanted you know this
intro feels like you can can see a kid
describe you then they cross here and
they use a beer and then you go through
this little I own these jumping around
they disappeared behind the game my god
like it has that energy which is really
good as Bryan Singer with a bunch of
x-men figurines this still holds up yes
this is really fucking cool like the one
great scene singer put in these movie
piece I'm glad that they kept Alan
Cummings real teeth it's like all of a
sudden they're like a real movie popped
out
hey yeah like an x-men movie like there
was nothing in x-men 1 that was like
that Gene's rocking the bling Jesus
Christ yes like an Oscar necklace or
something look at that Sheen that looks
like she's auditioning for Black Widow
in the Avengers yes you know even when
they get a really good actress to play
her Jean is one of those boring
characters yeah the only cool thing
about her is that she was Phoenix
everything else I've seen about Jean
it's like okay cool she's the emotional
Center people could talk to her right
now there's a boring character now since
there are so many witnesses I will have
to kill them all thousand heads explode
like lemmings
I'm Brian Cox I dunno is that a jet what
kind of jet we don't know it's an sr-71
what do you mean you don't know here's
one of the things - even though I know
he's a bad guy uses it for his evil
means I'm kind of on his side at first
like how does this school have a fighter
jet yeah okay okay if you're anyone and
this person who you touch can kill you
is just like hi
these lights represent every living
person on the planet say lot of people
watching porn right now cerebros a lot
better in this one yeah hey there's
actual color here do you think it looks
like I'm wearing a giant heart I think
it's pretty the Kara barrels don't be
designed us the mind is not a box can be
simply unlocked and opened its behind it
looked like he was making up his analogy
it's not a box you can open and close
itself wobbly I don't know anything so
as part of her powers super warmth
because how is she not freezing her ass
off in every sea excuse me break my
heart as she emerges from the wall
covered in industry seriously where
what's wrong all the kids were going one
direction I'm going this way
why
stay away from the manger babies go I'll
be fine but we won't like seriously
you're pretty badass and we're all
useless it seems to be the movies theme
I love just how like this baby seal guys
are just like run and bogs just walking
yeah when it explodes totally would have
hit him like yes see those are could see
the particles like items like that was
that we've been really stupid of him so
see just driving with one hand at his
club if you stab an ignition and makes
it magically work
don't you know runs into Batman coming
the other way
so that's mystique in the army I think
anyone can get into this damn place
honestly watching this again right after
the first one is like it's still clunky
but there are more scenes I'm like yeah
that was cool yeah that was pretty neat
yeah there isn't a lot of action just
like the first one but I feel like what
action there is it's gonna pull off
better found some of my mom's old
clothes buying shirts pretty clothes god
I just be amazing my god Brooke are you
still talking he makes himself an ice
mirror exactly are you professor of mr.
Logan art cut to him as guest on in
Beauty and the Beast kill the bees
oh yeah we're in this movie yeah
remember us sometimes anger can help you
like who's this storm like she's the one
that's supposed to be more level-headed
and like calming people down and stuff
like that and what's ironic is that she
technically gets better in every film
like you got a badasses stuff but it's
like it's still not really stor I feel
like Halle Berry from the beginning I
always thought was miscast her and rogue
the Iceman
got it holy crap Frank is that an sr-71
we don't know what it is so what am i
doing for the next 12 scenes in this
movie you're sitting in the chair and
staring yeah the more I think about it
that's like all he does throughout the
rest of the film I'm not sure I liked
any of this I'm just not that insurance
I'm never thinking this is where the
boredom started to set in in both the
comic and the cartoon you see all the
cool mind stuff when you're in someone's
mind and all the weird image and stuff
and this is not on here going through a
man like how cool would it be if there
was like putting up walls they were fine
in that so a cool so now we could just
reuse the same set
how have they said Gina bizza character
that's what bother me with her like oh
we're gonna do the the Phoenix thing and
in part three but what do we know but I
come yeah I'm like what have you set up
in these first two movies nothing I did
always like cuz like that's something
that happens in the comics a weird
on-again off-again alliances of
convenience but oh yeah I like that in
this one I don't like you but we need to
work together so that I can not like you
again at a later date they say you're
the bad guy it's because I do bad things
if that's the worst they say about me
I'm coming up pretty good
don't you real pyro I think you should
be Spyro like the cute little purple
dragon I'll take my chances but I was
I love missed it like I like her in this
series of films - she's better in the
comics but she's pretty cool in this she
just she doesn't need to see much she
just says they look like yeah I'm a fuck
shit up and it's more than just the
makeup she legit has a cool no yeah no
shear and smarting her her body acting
but no like it all series is her her
body acting like the way she carries
herself and everything like totally I
feel like a Bond villain I see you put
the pieces together quite perfectly
everyone oh yes okay it slows down the
energy it slows down momentum it's just
yeah you're right it's just so slow
again singer is incapable of making a
movie that is now boring on some level
and this is the better one still I'm
pretty convinced but even here it's
still moments of just dull I'm helpful
save your children here's an arse he's
like gonna see where he was made as to
but yet was he discovered nothing oh no
that was my that pissed me off the most
about this movie is I'm like wow so we
wait to find out like Wolverines origins
even find out jack shit okay tricky
thing about adamantium is that's one of
my favorite words to say adamantium I
must say I love hearing it I love saying
it it's a great I prefer unobtanium
I know knows that I just loved it
swishing the cave like my cape doesn't
deserve to touch you
something I'm just realizing this would
have been a much better plot point for
x3
you've got Xavier nearly killing all
mutants you've got him done nearly
killing all humans like that's a big
steak I feel like they blew their load
early on this one that's true although I
like I like the conflict with the kid
with the cure and everything like that
was interested but you're right it's not
a bigger stage you can't really top this
yeah
she's just a little good no she's not
it's really a guy in a wheelchair
be careful wait I'm the franchise aha
stabbing electrical things that always
closes doors can we get going Logan
please thank but somebody helped I think
all greens kidnapping me yes mr.
president even though I nearly
accidentally killed everybody get some
good PR behind them now we can work with
it
to be fair someday in the future
according to the movie Logan I will also
kill all mutants yeah so that's all the
way back these movies are fucking no
this series has been so inconsistent
even good ones when you get down to it
make knows we and then this bullshit
about like no no jean has to go out
there and lift the plane there's like
completely Star Trek to for no reason
Spock the closest I see is like
president Mitt Romney you could tell
that they're just like now we're not
gonna push it
he's gonna be slightly southern this is
gonna be a mix of it that was like it
was either random southern white dude
dignified black would you define random
and southern black woman that would be
the ultimate man hybrid of Hollywood
president yes I love me they finally
gave her an outfit like she's an x-man
now and it's like she's still not really
gonna do my actually still just that's
my power yeah like they are threatening
okay well we should declare war on all
music yeah right like it's not quite x3
bad but this is a really bad and
watching it like this is and nobody
nobody was watching this speech going
what the hell happened in the middle of
this yeah or what did he freeze all the
people in the war matches man but even
let's just imagine
Rosaura split second and in the middle
of the speech he's just can you imagine
if a print like well I guess we've got
try now so who the hell knows but can
you imagine president just like having a
weird breakdown moment like that just
like it's okay the mutant who tried to
kill us all just talked to me and said
leave mutants a lot and just the whole
world so Logan I hear you are new art
professor yeah I decided just to go with
it it was you wait wait she had a thing
with you and what he's teaching all
these varying different ages the exact
same thing aren't there grades it's like
even the music duh duh you're right
exactly man that it's rough that got a
little worse what well I guess start it
started off really strong I was like wow
like maybe was that you bear that I
remember it but as it kept going it just
got worse my thoughts the same I like
the story in the first x-men better
it was a tight it was it was a tighter
narrative there was a narrative that a
beginning middle and end yes there's a
hey we'll find out about Wolverine Civ
but that story itself like about the
x-men on that mission concluded I don't
know what the conclusion is with this
one cuz we didn't learn anything new
about Wolverine Jean Grey is now dead
and it's if you like this movie doesn't
feel like it ended just so much as
arbitrarily stopped I guess about the
same but for different reasons that I
remember it's still an okay
but yeah for for almost the exact
opposite should I reveal better than the
first two Wolverine films and still
better than X fear x-men apocalypse
that's about it we'll see you at X 3
ticket
you